probleme probleme probleme aber welche
probleme haben bei den deutschen in den
vergangenen 20 jahren dominiert und
wurden bei befragungen am häufigsten
genannt was hat sich verändert
genau das schauen wir uns in diesem
video an die top drei der wichtigsten
probleme
[Musik]
was ist eurer meinung nach gerade das
wichtigste problem dass wir in
deutschland haben
ich habe es gerne unten in die
kommentare ich bin gespannt was ich da
so einfällt wenn ihr vom
meinungsforschungsinstitut
forschungsgruppe wahlen angerufen werden
dann könnte das die erste frage sein die
ihr hören werdet seit 1995 schon stellen
sie den menschen in deutschland
regelmäßig diese frage für das
politbarometer und man muss sagen
seitdem ist er wirklich so passiert
das world trade center in flammen das
auswärtige amt spricht eine reisewarnung
aus
und diesmal gilt sie für die ganze welt
wir berg an problemen ist gewachsen
wir versuchen ihn heute zu erklimmen
anhand der daten der forschungsgruppe
wahlen schauen wir uns an welche
probleme am häufigsten genannt wurden
bei den befragungen und wir starten
jetzt mit unserer zeitreise und schauen
uns diese grafik zu den
umfrageergebnissen an
es geht um die frage nach den
wichtigsten problemen in deutschland
seit 2000 der dritthöchste peak
insgesamt liegt am 26 märz 2021
okay das war eine ziemlich kurze zeit
reist klar platz drei corona sicher
keine überraschung am 27 januar 2020
infizierte das neuartige virus den
ersten menschen in deutschland
was danach geschah das wisst ihr selbst
nur zu gut mehr infos zum thema findet
ihr in dieser play ist hier oben auf dem
i fällig zum ersten mal tochter corinna
virus in der auswertung der umfrage am
17 februar 2020 auch mit gerade einmal
zwei prozent
danach verläuft die kurve aber fast
senkrecht nach oben und wir sind damals
quasi eingetaucht also nur im
übertragenen sinne in die phase in der
das virus unser leben in vielerlei
hinsicht bestimmte mit shut down und
allem was dazu gehört
anfangs 2020 wurde es zum ersten mal als
wichtigstes problem genannt
im märz 2020 lag bei 85 prozent
der bisherige höchstwert beim thema
corona der dritthöchste für alle themen
aber jetzt könnte man sich natürlich
fragen worin sehen die befragten
eigentlich das problem also meinen die
befragten eher verona ist total
gefährlich und bedroht mein leben oder
acht diese ganze hysterie und maßnahmen
rund um corona sind total übertrieben
die persönlichen haltung wird im prinzip
nicht abgefragt
wir fragen was die menschen am meisten
beschäftigt was für sie das wichtigste
problem darstellt aber wir fragen nicht
nach der haltung die die befragten zu
diesem thema einnehmen
und wenn es ein thema ist es in der
bevölkerung auch sehr umstritten ist wie
zum beispiel auch corona oder andere
themen
dann kann es schon sein dass einfach
ganz konträre unterschiedliche gründe
vorlägen für die befragten warum sie
dieses
als wichtigstes problem r8 also egal
welche individuellen haltungen dahinter
stecken der themenkomplex sorgt für den
dritthöchsten ausschlag bei den
wichtigsten problemen für rang zwei
müssen wir noch ein paar jahre weiter
zurück nämlich ins jahr 2015 oder sind
wir bei platz nummer zwei ausländer
schrägstrich integration schrägstrich
flüchtlinge das thema ausländer
asylbewerber zuwanderung integration
das gehört bereits seit beginn der
befragung fast ohne unterbrechung zu den
am häufigsten genannten problemen der
menschen in deutschland in den jahren
2015 und 2016 gaben immer mehr als vier
von fünf befragten das als wichtigstes
problem an
bis zum ende des jahres 2015 überschritt
die zahl der schutzsuchenden in
deutschland die marke von mehr als einer
million und ein statement von
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel ging viral
wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das einige wochen nach diesem
statement am 15 oktober wird der höchste
wert auf der kurve erreicht 88% neues
system aber natürlich nicht auch in den
1990 er jahren wurde es schon am
häufigsten genannt jetzt sicher schon
gemerkt dass das thema hier sehr
allgemein gefasst ist dieses problem
umfasst ziemlich viele themenfelder in
einem fragen wir nochmal nach warum
heißt es ausländer asylbewerber
zuwanderung und integration in der
befragung noch komplizierter kann man es
ja fast gar nicht ausdrücken
warum also so umständlich und schwammig
wenn wir jetzt jede einzelne nennung er
diese frage kommt ein eckchen auch
ausweisen würden dann hätten wir eine
ganz lange liste an themen die alle mit
ganz wenigen prozent nur besetzt sind
das heißt wir hätten überhaupt keinen
überblick mehr über diese liste und
deshalb müssen wir themen zu
themenbereichen zusammenfassen das ist
manchmal nicht so einfach vor allem gibt
es überlappungen also es gibt auch
themen die man durchaus zwei
verschiedenen bereichen zuordnen könnte
und da diese frage ja eine offene frage
ist orientieren wir uns einfach immer an
den an den ersten begriffen giga
befragte dann nennen ja und damit sind
wir bei platz eins arbeitslosigkeit für
den allerhöchsten wert müssen wir ein
paar jahre weiter zurück gehen ins jahr
2005 und zwar im 18 märz 90 prozent der
befragten
damals als wichtigstes problem das
stichwort arbeitslosigkeit viele jahre
bei arbeitslosigkeit das mit abstand
dominierende thema
zum ersten januar 2005 wird hartz iv
eingeführt das arbeitslosengeld 2
weitgehend auf das niveau der vorherigen
sozialhilfe angepasst es ist eine der
größten sozialreformen in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg mit erheblichen einschnitten
für viele bereits im vorfeld wurde lange
darüber gestritten und auch danach
inzwischen hat sich die zahl der
befragten die die arbeitslosigkeit als
das dringendste problem in deutschland
sehen auf ein niedrigeres niveau
eingependelt und daran sieht man ganz
gut die umfragen sind immer auch ein
spiegel der jeweiligen zeit die themen
die die menschen bewegen variieren mit
dem aufkommen von price for future
erreicht zum beispiel auch das thema
umwelt einen peak 2009 10
ich will auch gar nicht werten welches
problem das relevanteste aller zeiten
ist oder ob ein problem früher wichtiger
war als heute wir schauen nur auf die
zahlen
wer sich einen überblick über die
weiteren probleme verschaffen will der
schaut einfach mal in die infobox da
geht es weiterführende links und auch
ansonsten informationen die euch ein
bisschen weiter helfen die frage ist
aber natürlich auch wie kommen die
zahlen für die wichtigsten probleme beim
politbarometer überhaupt zustande
gibt es da eine vorgefertigte liste mit
problemen oder gespannte an und fragt
dann hey wie gehts ihnen haben so ein
problem ja ach ist das denn
und dann kriegt man vielleicht eine
antwort ja also gestern da hat meine
tante lisbeth gesagt dass sie irgendwie
ein problem hat beim kuchenessen der
schmeckt ihnen nicht mehr so gut also ja
keine ahnung so läuft natürlich nicht ab
im prinzip bekommt man die frage die ich
euch bereits weiter am anfang des videos
gestellt habe was ist ihrer meinung nach
gegenwärtig das wichtigste problem in
deutschland
und dann gibt es keine vorgaben man kann
sagen was man will und das gleich
doppelt denn man darf sogar zwei themen
nennen und dadurch dass es die erste
frage ist kann man auch nicht durch
andere fragen und themen später
beeinflusst werden das wäre auch eine
möglichkeit dass man da fragen gestellt
bekommt die einander zuerst bringen zu
denken ach das ist ein problem
übrigens geht es um politische probleme
nicht die privaten von tante lisbeth und
den kuchen oder andere dinge sehr von
der methodik dahinter nicht genug
bekommen kann und sich jetzt brenne
dafür interessiert wie die befragten
überhaupt ausgewählt werden
mehr infos dazu ihr werdet euch schon
gedacht haben gibt es unten
in der infobox welches thema bewegt euch
denn am meisten
man hat euch das ranking überrascht
platz 12 platz drei oder sagt dir habe
ich mir schon gedacht schreibt es gerne
unten in die kommentare
und hier leben hier findet ihr noch ein
video zu geschonten arbeitslosenzahlen
von meinen kollegen vom zdf magazin
royal und hier noch ein video dazu warum
wahlumfragen gerade bei der afg in der
vergangenheit immer wieder daneben lagen
sag euch fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]